I feel like it's gonna be a great
experience
no no today we're gonna shave my legs
not looking forward to it
very afraid I'm actually excited about
this is that weird how do women do it
I've got a lot of hair
it's been building up for 25 years maybe
at the end of this I'll have nicer
shaped legs and my girlfriend all right
let's do this I don't even know what I'm
that's kind of gross I really get up
there now the fun part begins I don't
know if I'm supposed to go like against
the grain or with it clean strokes clean
strokes like I'm like husking corn or
something look at this the first clean
spot oh my god oh damn that's smooth how
many ladies get the back of the leg
that's what I'm like confused about I
can't see it and I don't have the yoga
capabilities to like twist my body back
there I think I might've just nicked
something back here maybe Oh
feels so weird look at the difference
look at like just the the tan looking
difference it doesn't feel like my leg
you know it feels like it feels like a
piece of chicken I'm liking the results
calf is looking great it's just so oily
it's like sexy lady hairy man oh god I'm
like over it already this is a long
process this is gonna take forever
I feel like I'm gonna cut myself on my
knee okay we have our first sign of
blood a little little toe cut action I
also just found a freckle that I didn't
know I had oh there's like giant patches
that I guess I just like forgotten about
like shaving your legs it's such a
buildup and then it's just a lot of work
just your oh all right yeah all right
that took a span of like what four to 20
or 40 minutes
feel like my legs look weird they just
look like these hot dogs I will say
feeling it now it feels kind of good
ooh I've got a nice gloss though look at
that look at the way the light like
reflects I underestimated how long it
takes to shave legs the process is
straight up a pain in the ass if I was a
girl and I had to do this every day I
probably just wear pants and not do it
I'm kind of scared to see what happens
when it grows
so this is three days later this whole
weekend it was just itchy like I felt
like I had an allergic reaction to
shaving it's been very sensitive I've
bet my legs are crazy sensitive someone
told me they would feel good against the
sheets and it does not I wore shorts
over the weekend and just because when I
sweat felt weird on my jeans and then
you realize you like mist patches you
look gross I will say this though
showers have been increasingly easier
like with drying it's just like I am
getting stubs I'm gonna matte stubs
right now I think this has made me
realize just how ridiculous this
pressure is and if somebody's not into
you could get hairy legs then they gonna
just move along
just think about off like the other
things you could be doing to your life
so for shaving your legs you could like
go to the gym get your cancer you could
get a new pet